i
[Música]
ah
según el observatorio nacional de
crímenes de odio el eje bet en 2019
ocurrieron en argentina 177 crímenes de
odio contra personas de esos colectivos
más que en los dos años anteriores de
las víctimas 113 fueron mujeres trans y
el 44% de los crímenes fueron asesinatos
o fueron muertes por ausencia o abandono
estatal argentino ha realizado avances
en materia de normativa y legislación de
género entre los que se incluyen
derechos y protecciones para las
personas trans
por ejemplo el odio la orientación
sexual o la identidad de género es un
agravante en los casos de homicidio y
lesiones sin embargo en argentina las
personas trans siguen siendo
especialmente víctimas de violencia no
sólo física sino también laboral
sanitaria y habitacional entre otras
todo lleva a que la expectativa de vida
promedio de las mujeres trans esté muy
por debajo de la del resto de la
población y se ubique aproximadamente
entre los 35 y los 40 años
[Música]
en colombia el 24 de septiembre juliana
giraldo mujer transexual de 38 años
viajaba en un automóvil por una
carretera del departamento del cauca en
ese trayecto un soldado del ejército le
disparaba en la cabeza y terminaba con
su vida un caso mediático que pone de
relieve la indefensión del colectivo
trans así como los excesos de la
violencia policial y militar en colombia
pero juliana no es una excepción
la organización red comunitaria trans
denuncia que en 2020 al menos 28
personas trans habrían sido asesinadas
en el país una violencia que aseguran
que viven de forma cotidiana en bogotá a
la capital el 8% de los casos de
violencia policial son contra personas
trans pero el colectivo también denuncia
violencia institucional como en el caso
de alexandra una trans con vih que
habría muerto en plena pandemia sin ser
atendida correctamente y además tras
fallecer su cuerpo no fue retirado hasta
14 horas después la asociación colombia
diversa registra un promedio de 110
asesinatos anuales de personas lgtbi
desde 2014 números que sitúan a colombia
como el segundo país con más asesinatos
de este colectivo en américa
solo superado por brasil
[Música]
la pandemia de coronavirus ha puesto de
manifiesto la problemática a la que se
enfrentan las personas lgtb en el
salvador en particular las mujeres trans
para las que la violencia y desigualdad
son una realidad permanente son en los
primeros tres meses de cuarentena por
kobe 19 más de 100 mujeres transgénero
fueron atendidas por la organización con
cádiz 13 de los casos fueron por abuso
de autoridad
específicamente detenciones arbitrarias
también hubo de 19 denuncias por falta
de asistencia en el sistema de salud
público y 57 en situación de
desplazamiento forzado la comunidad
trans también ha denunciado que el
confinamiento las ha obligado a vivir
con familiares y parejas que son
maltratadores durante la pandemia se ha
registrado un aumento de las denuncias
de violencia de género en el ámbito
familiar extorsión desalojo intento de
homicidio e incluso suicidio sin embargo
las mujeres transgénero encuentran
mayores obstáculos para acceder a la
justicia debido a la discriminación y
estigmatización
[Música]